this is a tragedy in the humanitarian
crisis which is on a par with Syria or
Yemen see small children in such a
desperate State is really quite
upsetting the DRC is one of the most
difficult places to work in in the world
because there are so many hidden dangers
and so many geographical difficulties
the landscape itself is almost
impossible to cross it's great to go in
with the UN because that affords you a
certain amount of protection but you are
mercy in terms of whether you get on a
plane or whether you get on a truck
being journalists you're right low down
pecking order
a lot of the areas that we were going to
were very remote and involved huge long
periods of traveling we set out to try
and get a snapshot of the chaos that's
engulfing the country just how many
people were in desperate need of help
how many people have died how many
people work homeless they seem to be
large numbers of the country which were
running away from attacks or different
militia
we knew that there was not only a
humanitarian tragedy on a massive scale
but also that the government and the
authorities were denying it hospital
just to check it out so many people
being displaced or images the attacks
basically lack of food I'm not a big fan
of going into hospitals at the best of
times but this hospital in DRC was
overrun with people that had been the
victim of machete attacks people that
were ill through disease when he went in
the beds were all crowded at least two
to bed no different families sharing the
same bed too many babies to cope with
the whole thing is encapsulated by the
undernourished babies that were being
born prematurely
the tiny one on the Rights was born
three weeks ago his mother had given
birth 14 weeks prematurely so this baby
really shouldn't have lived and on top
of that the mother who was also
undernourished how much did the baby
weighs 750 I didn't even realize our two
babies in the cartman when we started to
film the car I just saw the one on the
left
I thought it was just a bundle of
bedclothes on the right didn't even look
like it was alive their baby started to
cry and out it was tough
this little bird like cry coming out he
seemed to sum up everything about DRC
because he was utterly helpless he'd
been born into this country starving and
he's probably gonna spend the rest of
his life starving and who knows how long
that life is going to be the doctor was
like one of those unsung heroes who's
going around just trying to help these
people with hardly anything his
imaginative commercial animated movie
premiere party parmigiana call it the
Mercury's effectiveness
and he'd show us these children whom he
really didn't think there was any hope
for them but he wasn't going to give up
because the parents were there and he
wanted to show them that he was doing
absolutely everything he could to try
and save their child just after half
5:00 in the morning so it's still what's
gonna happen the rest of the day it was
a country that appeared to be completely
in anarchy under huge sections
the risk is medium here the risk is high
please pay attention all the time about
your security one of the big challenges
was after me getting there and it took
hours and hours on the back of a UN
truck to actually get to one of the
scenes where there'd be a massacre
the roads were best really really bad
there's so many bumps and the truck
suspension wasn't very kind to us we
went past village of the village of
burnt homes destroyed homes as we were
driving through the UN soldiers would be
looking out watching these carcasses of
homes and therefore shells of people's
lives the truck stopped and we were told
that we were going into the high-risk
zone
immediately all the soldiers changed
their demeanor and they were ready for
any form of attack and it put us on
guard as well you really got a sense
that you were going into the badlands
their group had been attacked before
other peacekeepers have been killed in
this country from that moment on
everybody was aware that an attack could
be likely to my surprise they had razor
wire they had men on point and within
about an hour they'd built a secure camp
around us we were right next to Lake
Albert a scene of absolute stunning
beauty but also where there had
obviously been some Massacre or tragedy
there was graffiti on the walls of some
of the mud hut saying which rebel group
that they were from these peacekeepers
had been given a tip-off that there were
a number of shallow graves they set off
along the beach not knowing what they
were going to see or what they were
going to find there are one and quite
soon you could smell this putrid smell
the peacekeepers themselves I think were
quite shocked at seeing these corpses
turning up it was pretty distressing
[Music]
there's been violence now in the DRC for
decades and there are so many different
militia and groups that are fighting
that a lot of time nobody knows quite
who they are or why the fighting is even
happening it was a very strong feeling
this fighting was perpetuated by certain
sections of the government the president
is promising elections but people really
suspect he doesn't want to have
elections and it serves the president's
purpose if there is lots of conflict in
the country we went to another village
talking to a whole crowd of people many
of whom would displace many of whom have
nothing then in amongst this crowd I saw
a very young girl on her back she
carried a baby and the girl herself
looked in terrible state but the baby
looked half alive and I just quietly
gave guy a signal to say look at this
baby here she's absolutely desperate
I've never seen anything like it
she looked bill she looks sick and she
looked in distress and it's a strange
emotion here's somebody who's clearly in
distress in these medical assistance
immediately yet we're there to take
pictures and in ten minutes we're gone
and they looked really bedraggled three
children all together she looked very
thin and covered in dirt and dust and
the baby had yellowy hair indicating it
that they were suffering from lack of
food and it turned out that they'd been
separated from their parents during one
of the attacks and
they didn't know where the parents were
you know that you've got these rations
would probably more food than they've
had for four weeks do you think we can
try and give them some water or
something to eat pretty desperate
situation I think yes we're just a
thought
bugger it we're gonna try and help these
kids in just gonna be tiny tiny tiny
help and it's more actually helping our
guilty conscience rather than helping
them because in long term it's not going
to help them it's not gonna solve their
problems Nick we felt we had to try and
help but at the same time we didn't know
how that was going to turn out for them
because everybody then became quite
agitated at the sight of food being
passed out
I have children of my own and seeing
small children like that in such a
desperate state is really quite
upsetting it's very hard to keep
composure when you are actually filming
because you can see that all the people
around desperate as well and they're
desperate enough not to care that these
are small children on their own they're
desperate enough to do anything to
survive themselves
so they just want to check that the kids
are alright that foods gonna disappear
all the way we nominated the sort of
elder statesman of the community and he
took it off with them holding their
hands and I just had a really sinking
feeling that they probably not going to
see any of it
I really felt helpless and I felt felt
like we're just not doing enough to help
these people
every place we went to it became evident
that people were suffering
we visited an IDP camp where there were
thousands of these displaced people who
had come from all kinds of villages
where we had been we're just going to
enter the camp now the IDP in dunya
I can guarantee within about five
minutes we're gonna get mobbed it's kids
enough families they said there was
nearly ten thousand people and this was
just one of the camps which had sprung
up out of nowhere we all knew there were
a whole load more people out there who
haven't even got to the camps so these
camps were just a small portion of what
was happening around the country
particularly in that province
they'd have to flee their villages
they're living in abject poverty and
they're sleeping and surviving some
pretty tough conditions they still find
in them to be like children to play
[Music]
[Applause]
we were told that there were many people
who are attacked so we went to one tent
and they said they had people who were
victims of a machete attack little girl
how old this little toddler who's
stumbling along you know it was only two
years old and she's got this huge big
slash across her face I mean it's it's
really difficult to imagine anyone who
could do that
I mean you've taken a machete and you
smashed it onto a little child's face
but then he tried again because she had
a big gash on the back of her head the
the cruelty is pretty unimaginable and
then her father came interview his face
was just a picture of misery and shock
he'd seen his wife already killed and
then they started attacking his children
and so he intervened and he was covered
in about scars it was just quite a shock
to see the kind of violence that can be
inflicted and then we discovered that
she had an older sister he'd also been
machete
they'd chopped her hand off and we
interviewed this family who were
grateful just to be alive yet were
carrying the scars of the most
horrendous violence and that was that
was quite a shocking scene to come
across and to film this that's to watch
me like someone who wants to kill a
goats
we're hearing that little girl would
count the story of her attack was really
quite chilling this was just this young
little girl talking like that I think
there are so many problems in the world
that it perhaps just feels like one more
but what I don't think the world
realizes is just how much suffering
there is in the DRC the images of the
children will not go away when there is
such evidence of such large-scale
suffering and the government is
continuing to say there isn't a
humanitarian crisis
it's quite hard to remain unemotional
about that